[Musique]
José Legault Émilie Nicolas Christian
Dufour bonsoir
je vais développer un nouveau concept je
vais me faire un calcul il nous reste 15
16 minutes 5 chefs fait 3 minutes par
chef trois minutes par chef on commence
allons-y je suis devenu fou depuis
on va passer chaque chef on va pas
réinventer la formule François Legault
je commence avec vous José qu'avez-vous
pensé de sa performance dans ce débat
hier soir
c'était pas encore je pense à la hauteur
de ce que Premier ministre sortant qui
caracole encore au sommet des sondages
et qui s'en va vers une victoire
aurait dû être quand même là on l'a pas
vu vraiment plus souriant quoi que moi
l'obsession du sourire je suis pas sûr
on l'a vu surtout crispé impatient on
reviendra tout à l'heure sur cette
attaque aussi le contre-résidienne qui
l'a qui l'a reprise ce matin quand même
très étonnante et j'écoutais le maire la
bombe tout à l'heure qui qui parlait de
faussés générationnel entre monsieur
Legault et les quatre autres chefs moi
je dirais pas que c'est une question
d'âge parce que je dirais que c'est plus
un faux c'est politique et on a vu
vraiment que monsieur Legault et une
vision très très différente des quatre
autres Émilie Nicolas
je pense que en fait ça va être densifié
par certains depuis le début là que le
slogan de la carte qui est un peu
dangereux au sens où continuons c'est
parfait quand ça va bien c'est moins
évident comme message principal quand ça
va moins bien donc dans les débats
puisqu'il n'est pas en contrôle des
sujets mais ça nous amène à parler de
réalité qui sont vraiment pas facile en
ce moment au Québec dont l'inflation
dans la situation en système de santé
dont la situation dans le système
scolaire donc François Legault pour pas
avoir à défendre un bilan qui est
difficile à défendre je pense que
tendance à dire que les alternatives
seraient encore pire ça l'amène à
pointer du doigt Gabriel à l'eau du bois
ça l'appelle maintenant pointer du doigt
iriduel mais essentiellement ça ça crée
ça crée une atmosphère où on fait
toujours baisser les attentes en disant
ouais c'est vrai qu'il y a encore des
problèmes mais il pourra en avoir encore
plus et c'est ça qu'on vend la
population essentiellement donc c'est
sûr que ça fait un contrat c'est
important avec les autres chefs de
parties qui essayent de nous vendre un
peu plus de rêves que
ça pourrait être encore pénible
moi je suis pragmatique vous ne l'êtes
pas vous Christian Dufour
je trouve qu'il s'en est bien sorti
globalement il a pas été transcendant
mais il y avait pas l'être du tout c'est
le premier ministre en fait c'est
comporté comme un premier ministre que
gouverner le Québec depuis 4 ans comme
père de famille en fait donc il demande
à son discours était moins noir et blanc
bon il expliquait ce qu'il y avait
essayé de faire ce qui semble avoir
réussi bon il attaquer les autres il y a
pas dérapés il y a pas dérailler donc
pour lui je trouve qu'il s'en sort
globalement bien parce qu'il y avait pas
à prier là c'est c'est le premier
certain couple d'oublier très bien
Dominique Anglade José Legault même
exercice
ben là on a vu ce qu'elle ce qu'elle
entendait par vous allez voir la vraie
Dominique et bon et là je suis pas
référence à la petite danse là
en vidéo avant le débat mais c'est que
finalement ce que j'ai vu c'est un peu
la stratégie Obama
lorsqu'il s'est présenté et dans tous
ses discours il essayait de
personnaliser
des des des dossiers bon soit avec
lui-même soit en prenant comme exemple
des citoyens des citoyens elle est
Madame Maria le faisait avec les
infirmières sur la santé mentale elle a
parlé de sa propre mère sur la
conciliation travail famille et le recul
aussi
de la situation des femmes avec le
manque de place en CPE etc elle l'a
vraiment incarné aussi avec des exemples
donc c'est c'était vraiment ça c'est
l'humanisation par la personnalisation
des enjeux tandis que rapidement
monsieur Legault lui a plus tendance à
répondre en donnant des chiffres on
investi 100 millions 800 millions 22
millions mais mais une personnalise pas
et ça semble manquer d'empathie donc je
pense que c'était ça
très bien la question c'est ce que ça
peut faire bouger les aiguilles
au niveau du vote on va voir les
libéraux remonter dans les sondages dans
les prochains jours mais c'est sûr que
ça sa performance était bien meilleure
j'ai trouvé que celle du premier débat
de la semaine dernière
ceci dit c'est un peu peut-être que
c'est un peu trop peu trop tard au sens
où ça fait déjà longtemps que les chefs
de l'opposition officielle on est rendu
à plus de la moitié de la campagne et
c'est comme si elle se présentait en
fait dans le débat d'hier soir où elle
était là en train de dire bonjour je
m'appelle Dominique voici qui je suis
donc tant mieux si ça fonctionne mais
peut-être qu'on aurait en fait aimé voir
ça plutôt d'accord Christian
ben moi je l'aime bien d'habitude mais
hier ça m'a mis profondément mal à
l'aise sa petite danse le côté human
intérêt c'était très artificiel en fait
faisait très préparé en terme de contenu
parce que j'ai retenu c'est l'attaque
dévastatrice d'Éric dum au sujet du
dossier linguistique quand tu l'as
appelé cette vérité que dans un premier
temps Madame Anglade
est le même boulot la renforcer puis
ensuite elle a complètement changé de
position parce qu'il y avait du problème
chez les anglophones ça c'était vraiment
dévastateur mais pour le reste moi je
suis pas très sensible à ce genre de je
comprends pas que les gens trouvaient ça
merveilleux c'était tellement évident
qu'à faire un effort pour avoir l'air
humaine
moi j'aime bien l'habitude mais il faut
tout faire une petite danse dans salle
de maquillage pour avoir le même c'est
avant le débat pour que les gens
comprennent et c'est avant le départ
très bien Gabriel ado Dubois José
continuer vraiment sur sa lancée puisque
le Premier ministre sortant lui a fait
l'honneur depuis un an de désigner comme
son adversaire unique et bien sûr que il
continue lui-même à jouer ce rôle là et
on a vu sur plusieurs dossiers aussi non
seulement face à monsieur Legault mais
on l'a vu même se montrer d'accord avec
pas simplement donc je suis parti
québécois
et
il y a des gens qui ont dû regretter
qu'il y a pas eu de convergence
oui non c'est donc c'est c'est la même
question que Madame anglaise
c'est-à-dire est-ce que ça va aider
quand même le Québec solidaire à élargir
ou pas sa base c'est ça réponse le 3
octobre
donc sur Gabriel ado Dubois ça va
peut-être pas les aider à bouger les
aiguilles mais ça va quand même aider
les gens à se faire une idée sur les
différents de Programmes puis la
conception de la société Émilie
absolument je pense que l'exercice hier
soir vraiment été très pédagogique
là-dessus pour vraiment comprendre en
fait quand votre pour une personne on
vote pour quelle idée plutôt que de
seulement voter pour une personnalité je
pense que c'est vraiment ce qui est
ressorti dans des body hier soir qui qui
est vraiment qui est vraiment important
comme exercice démocratique ceci dit je
pense que il y a vraiment Dubois c'est
un peu des fois faut faire attention à
ce que l'on souhaite je pense que il
souhaitait être l'adversaire principale
de François Legault mais ça a fait en
sorte hier soir que la grande majorité
de de ces interventions était pour des
répondre à François Legault donc et ça
le plaçait sur une défensive en fait où
il était en train de démonter le
vocabulaire de François Legault avant de
remonter son propre argumentaire donc je
pense que ça l'aide jusqu'à un certain
point d'être l'adversaire principal que
François Hugo a identifié mais trop
d'une bonne chose c'était
donc je pense que hier soir ça va
peut-être être un peu plus difficile que
ça leur aurait été s'il y avait s'il
avait été moins attaqué
souvent j'ai intéressant pour vous
monsieur nado Dubois il a fait 4-5 fois
dans le débat ouais bien pour Gabrielle
de Dubois hier que une semaine parce
qu'il est un peu trop sûr de lui très
théâtrale très idéologique je trouve que
le côté idéologique ressortait
énormément on a vêtements l'impression
que la planète est plus importante que
le Québec pour Gabriel Nadeau du bois et
je trouve que pour les citoyens
d'ailleurs le grand gagnant du
débrouilleurs c'est le vecteurs
québécois en fait qui connaît plus les
chefs et leur programme et j'en profite
pour féliciter Patrice parce que c'était
magistrats pour quelque chose c'était
passionnant alors que moi je trouve ça
ennuyeux souvent gabriol on a d'autres
du bois hier je trouve que les gens qui
l'aiment en construire les mains mais
moi je pense pas que convaincu d'autres
monde un peu trop déconnecté de la
réalité il y a quand même la réalité il
y a des limites à prendre ses rêves pour
la réalité aussi Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon qu'on a appris cette nuit qui
avait la fièvre on n'a pas vu ça
d'ailleurs peut-être qu'on l'a tous mais
comme j'ai dit
c'est s'enrhumés demain matin on verra
José Legault Paul Saint-Pierre plat
Mondon hier qu'en avez-vous pensé
ben lui aussi je pense que c'est un peu
la découverte de la campagne électorale
non seulement parce qu'il a continué à
marteler ses messages mais les continuer
à le faire de manière respectueuse pour
tout ce qu'on a remarqué ce qui est très
apprécié de la population que les gens
votent ou pas pour son parti et
d'ailleurs c'est moi aussi je je dirais
comme Christian l'exercice d'hier soir
c'était un exercice pédagogique et
démocratique et on voit que Monsieur pas
simplement a fait école parce que la
plupart du temps pendant le débat tout
le monde était assez respectueux les uns
des autres le format s'y prêtait aussi
mais je pense que ça a eu ça a eu une
influence et moi j'ai eu énormément
depuis hier soir de courriels d'appel
qui disent mon dieu c'est la première
fois que j'ai vraiment compris
les programmes et les idées les idées
respectives de chacun des chefs et de
chaque partie donc chapeau ça ce que
vous venez de dire c'est la chose qui
moi et toute l'équipe me fait le plus
plaisir c'est ça le but faut pas perdre
de ça de vue on fait une émission de
télévision et je le disais avant la
pause je vais le répéter quand on dit
les gens s'intéressent pas à la campagne
c'est totalement faux c'est le débat qui
a été le plus regardé chez nous depuis
13 ans un million.4 hier des vrais la
vraie télé je parle même pas du
numérique là ça monte beaucoup plus haut
TVA la semaine dernière un point 5 donc
en deux les gens
s'intéressent à cette campagne c'est fou
de dire que les gens s'intéressent pas
c'est des chiffres très forts très
solides et tout au long du débat les
gens sont restés ça même augmenté donc
qu'est-ce que je disais oui Eric duham
et c'est la preuve que c'est la preuve
que c'était intéressant
publique là on peut pas dire quelqu'un
qui dit là je suis pas au courant mais
désolé mais on vous a donné les outils
il reste combien de temps irréduiment
tour de table José
Eric Diem je pense qu'il y a eu il y a
reçu un immense cadeau de François
Legault hier justement à cet échange
très dur là où Monsieur le goût le
traité d'achittateur etc
je pense pas qu'il s'attendait à avoir
un cadeau comme ça parce que ça peut
même l'aider à consolider sa base qui
tout à coup on le voit comme une victime
dans ce scénario là mais bon il y a pas
il y a pas à part ça fait de flemme je
particulière là mais pour la première
fois il y a quand même expliqué mieux
son programme sur le privé en santé pour
ou contre Émilie
ça me donnait un peu l'impression de
voir l'équivalent provincial de ce qu'on
voit qu'on voit le Bloc québécois
fédéral au sens où c'est comme si Eric
duel s'adressait à la région de Québec
et parler des enjeux de Québec puis dans
un débat provincial mais en fait lui
c'était les représentants de la des
enjeux de la région de Québec et presque
uniquement de la région de Québec sur un
débat provincial donc ça donne un peu un
truc ou source lorsque ces enjeux-là
sont obligés de sur la table par exemple
le troisième lien notamment il était
très j'allais j'allais dire même presque
agressif c'est un des seuls en fait qui
a essayé de couper la parole aux autres
durant le débat et surtout les autres en
fait c'est comme s'il se battait pas en
fait nécessairement même pour essayer
d'avoir la parole pour essayer
d'expliquer son programme c'est lui je
pense d'ailleurs à la fin qui avait le
qui avait le moins parlé donc c'est
comme c'est sur les sujets que c'est pas
les sujets qui avaient sur sa maman il y
avait moins de choses à dire très bien
Christian c'est dommage que j'ai juste
15 secondes
un peu comme une note en mode page ou un
élément marginal je trouve qu'avec Paul
Saint-Père pas mon nom qui est brillait
très très clairement
eric duham a vraiment réussi
profondément quelque chose hier il
n'était pas spectaculaire il faut il
fallait pas qu'il le soit mais il
exprimé une série de position qui était
modérée qui était en dehors du consensus
québécois il a fait ça de façon brève
clair et efficace et moi je pense que
iris duvet un milliard il a gagné des
gens qui sont pas juste sa base objectif
un certain niveau certaines niveaux mais
exprimer l'opposition il est ailleurs il
est dans autre chose et il a réussi à
avoir l'air modéré il y avait pas très
bien qu'il y avait l'air modéré et là je
suis dommage qu'on est pas plus de temps
je trouve qu'il y avait on n'a jamais
assez le système médiatique
ça va la pause salut à la bonne fête
bonne fin de semaine tout le monde salut